♪ ♪
BEFORE HILLARY CLINTON ITCHING
FOR A REMATCH?
ATTACKING ON TWITTER AND
TAUNTING TO ENTER THE 2020 RACE.
CLIENT EMPOWERING BACK DON'T
TEMPT ME, DO YOUR JOB.
BUT HILLARY IS JUST JOKING,
RIGHT?
MAYBE NOT.
>> YOU KNOW, IT IS TRULY
REMARKABLE HOW HE REMAINS WITH
ME.
NOTHING HAS BEEN MORE EXAMINED
AND LOOKED AT THAN MY EMAILS.
WE ALL KNOW THAT.
SO HE IS EITHER LYING OR
DELUSIONAL OR BOTH.
MAYBE THERE DOES NEED TO BE A
REMATCH.
OBVIOUSLY, I CAN BEAT HIM AGAIN.
>> Dana: AND GREG WE CAN GO
HERE AGAIN.
>> Greg: THAT IS NOT AN
OBSESSION BUT A DILUTION ONE
HOLES TO KEEP OUT THE REALITY.
I DON'T BLAME HER.
SHE'S PROBABLY HAD TO SAY THESE
THINGS BEING MARRIED TO A MAN
WHO HAS VETTED MORE WOMEN THAN
MY PILLOW.
[LAUGHTER]
BY THE WAY, YOU KNOW SHE'S NOT
IMMUNE TO UKRAINE'S STUFF, IF
SHE ENTERS THIS PICTURE IT WILL
STAIN HER AS WELL.
>> Dana: WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT, SHE'S ON A BOOK TOUR SO
IT DOESN'T HURT TO HAVE A
LITTLE --
>> Greg: SHE'S LIKE A
CELEBRITY STALKER.
>> Jesse: YOU WILL FIND HER
OUTSIDE OF THE WHITE HOUSE WITH
A SECRET SERVICE.
IF YOU JUST LET ME END, YOU WANT
TO TALK TO ME.
BUT I THINK RIGHT NOW SHE IS
GOING BACK TO THE EMAILS AND
SAYS EVERYTHING WAS EXAMINED
EXCEPT FOR THE 33,000 SHE
ACTUALLY WHITEWASHED.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF SCHIFF
SUBPOENAS TRUMP OR AN EMAIL,
JUST ONE AND ASKED HIM
WHITEWASHED AS AN SAYS JUST ONE,
CAN YOU IMAGINE WHAT THE
REACTION WOULD BE?
AND SHE DID THAT TO 33,000,
HUGE, HUGE DOUBLE STANDARD.
LASTLY, IF SHE DOES GET IN, HERE
IS WHAT SHE'S LOOKING AT.
SHE IS LOOKING LIKE JOE AS TOAST
AND BERNIE, HER ONLY OPPONENT IS
LIZ WARREN.
AND SHE HAS TO SAY TO YOURSELF,
GUYS, LOOK AT THIS I BEAT TRUMP
IN THE POPULAR VOTE.
L RAISED HIM AND OUT, AND I CAN
BEAT HIM AGAIN IN WISCONSIN AND
I PROMISE I WILL PUT LIZ WARREN
ON THE TICKET AND BERNIE AND THE
CABINETS.
LET'S HAVE A REMATCH.
THAT IS CONVINCING TO SOME
DEMOCRATS.
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW, WE HAVE
A SECOND TOPIC IN A QUICK HIT
FROM THIS ON YOU.
>> Juan: THIS IS A WONDERFUL
G.O.P., HOW LONG HAS SHE BEEN
DEMONIZED BY REPUBLICANS?
SHE MAKES A SILLY COMMENT, AGAI
AGAIN.
>> Greg: SHE DIDN'T CALL
ANYBODY DEPLORABLE.
>> Kimberly: EVEN FOR HER OWN
OWN --
>> Juan: I DON'T BUY IT.
TRUMP IS OBSESSED WITH HER
BECAUSE SHE BEAT HIM IN THE
POPULAR VOTE.
>> Greg: HE'S IN THE
OVAL OFFICE.
>> Juan: BUT THE POPULAR VOTE,
HE SAYS, OH, NO, MY VOTERS THEY
WERE ILLEGAL ALIEN VOTERS.
>> Dana: IF SHE HAD BEATEN
HIM, SHE WOULD BE IN THE
OVAL OFFICE.
CALLING OUT HILLARY CLINTON AND
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION FOR MAKING
HER PUSH ON TROOP TALKING POINTS
AFTER THE GAUZY ATTACK.
DO YOU REMEMBER THIS?
IT BEGAN SPONTANEOUSLY
HENNEPIN COUNTY AND SPONTANEOUS
REACTION TO WHAT SPARKED THE
RECENT VIOLENCE WAS THE ERRING
ON THE INTERNET OF A VERY
HATEFUL, VERY OFFENSIVE VIDEO.
>> AND A NEW BOOK, WRITING ABOUT
CLINTON, WHY DO YOU HAVE TO GO
ON THE SHOW?
WHERE IS HILLARY?
AFTER A BRUTAL WAY, SHE WAS
UNRELENTING.
THIS IS NOT A GOOD IDEA.
CAN'T YOU GET OUT OF IT?
HILLARY WAS NOWHERE TO BE SEEN
AND WE TALK ABOUT THIS A LOT,
WHY DO THEY HAVE TO GO OUT AND
SAY THAT?
>> Greg: I REMEMBER IT LIKE IT
WAS FOUR YEARS AGO.
FIVE YEARS AGO, BUT THE THING IS
IT BRINGS UP A COMPARISON I SAID
BEFORE.
THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE BACK
THEN LAUGHING ABOUT BENGHAZI WHO
ARE WETTING THEIR PANTS OVER
UKRAINIAN PHONE CALL.
THERE IS NO COMPARISON FOR
AMERICAN SPIRITS BEFORE WE
TALKED ABOUT IT FOUR YEARS AGO.
>> Jesse: IT WAS THREE.
AND WHAT ABOUT BEN GAUZY AND THE
USED TO SAY, WHO IS MR. BEN
GAUZY?
>> Greg: SHE WAS A PASI, AND
THEY HAD TO COVER UP FOR THE
FACT THERE WAS A TERRORIST
ATTACK AFTER CAMPAIGN ON
DEFEATING AL QAEDA AND THE TRUTH
WAS, THE ADMINISTRATION DIDN'T
PROTECT THE AMBASSADOR ON THE
ANNIVERSARY OF 9/11 IN A COUNTRY
THEY HAD JUST TOPPLED AFTER A
YEAR OF SECURITY REQUEST.
SO THEY BLAMED A VIDEO GUY,
ACTUALLY WE STILL DON'T KNOW
WHAT REALLY HAPPENED BECAUSE DID
THEY FIGHT SOME SUBPOENAS?
I THINK THEY BOUGHT A FEW
SUBPOENAS BACK THEN.
>> Juan: IT IS INCREDIBLE AND
IMAGINE I DON'T THINK THERE WAS
ANY INVESTIGATION.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY HAD TO
TESTIFY.
I DON'T THINK REPUBLICANS WORE
THIS OUT AND JESSE.
>> Dana: IT IS INTERESTING,
GUYS, ALL THESE YEARS LATER, NOW
SUSAN RICE, I TOOK THE FALL FOR
HILLARY CLINTON ON THE DATA
HILLARY CLINTON PUTS A LITTLE
KILN IN THE WATER FOR RUNNING
FOR 2020.
>> Kimberly: AND I DON'T THINK
HILLARY SET ME UP ALTHOUGH MY
MOM DID.
BUT OBVIOUSLY, FRONT AND CENTER,
SHE DIDN'T HAVE THE RIGHT STORY
AND IT DERAILED HER WHOLE
CAREER.
ANY ASPIRATIONS FROM THAT POINT
ON WERE DESTROYED.
SHE WAS COMPLETELY DESTROYED IN
THE UNIVERSE AT BOTH SIDES ON
ONE POINT.
AND HILLARY CLINTON HAD TO DO IT
BECAUSE SHE HAD TO TAKE THE FALL
FOR THAT.
SHE WAS PERCEIVED AS A LIAR AND
INCLUDING HER EMAIL.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN OVER FOR